Vous serez contents de savoir que je ne vais pas vous parler de mes malheurs,
mais de ceux d’autrui.
Il est bien plus facile de parler légèrement des malheurs d’autrui que des siens
et je veux rester dans l’esprit de la conférence.
À en croire les médias,
être un dealer pendant le pic de l’épidémie de crack
c’était la belle vie, selon Virginia Postrel.
Argent, drogues, armes à feu, femmes,
bijoux, bling-bling... rien ne manquait.
Ce que je vais vous dire aujourd’hui, c’est qu’en fait, grâce à 10 années de recherches,
l’occasion unique d’aller à l’intérieur d’un gang
pour consulter la comptabilité réelle, les rapports financiers du gang,
c’est que la réponse s’avère très différente : appartenir à un gang, ce n’est pas la belle vie.
Au contraire, je pense qu’en réalité, appartenir à un gang
-- vendre des drogues pour un gang -- est sans doute le pire boulot qui soit en Amérique.
Et c’est de cela que j’aimerais vous convaincre aujourd’hui.
Donc, il y a trois choses que je veux faire.
D’abord, je veux expliquer comment et pourquoi le crack
a eu une tel retentissement sur les gangs de quartiers défavorisés.
Ensuite, je veux vous raconter comment quelqu’un comme moi
a pu en arriver à voir le fonctionnement interne d’un gang.
C’est une histoire intéressante, je pense.
Et enfin, je veux vous donner, rapidement,
quelques-unes des conclusions auxquelles nous sommes arrivés
en consultant les rapports financiers -- la comptabilité -- du gang.
Et avant cela, juste un avertissement :
cette communication a été classée « interdit aux moins de 18 ans ».
Elle aborde des thèmes d’adultes avec des mots d’adultes.
Sachant qui est sur scène, vous serez ravis d’apprendre qu’en fait
il n’y aura pas de nudité,
sauf en cas...
(Rires)
... d’accident vestimentaire fortuit.
Bien, commençons par le crack et comment il a transformé les gangs.
Pour cela, il faut remonter à une époque qui a précédé le crack,
au début des années 80, et adopter le point de vue d’un chef de gang.
Être chef de gang dans une cité n’était pas une mauvaise affaire au milieu des années 80.
Au début des années 80, pourrait-on dire.
On avait alors beaucoup de pouvoir, on pouvait tabasser du monde,
on avait beaucoup de prestige, beaucoup de respect.
Mais il n’y avait pas d’argent, n’est-ce pas ?
Les gangs n’avaient pas de moyen de se faire de l’argent.
Et on ne pouvait pas demander une cotisation aux membres du gang
parce que ces membres n’avaient pas d’argent.
On ne pouvait pas vraiment se faire de l’argent en vendant de la marijuana.
Il s’avère que la marijuana ne rapporte pas grand chose.
On ne s’enrichit pas à vendre de la marijuana.
On ne pouvait pas vendre de la cocaïne.
Vous savez, la cocaïne est un bon produit -- la cocaïne en poudre --
mais il faut connaître de riches blancs.
Et la plupart des gangs des cités ne connaissaient pas de riches blancs ;
ils ne pouvaient pas vendre à ce marché.
On ne pouvait pas se contenter non plus de la délinquance.
Il s’avère que la délinquance est une très mauvaise source de revenus.
Et donc,
en tant que chef de gang, on avait, vous voyez, du pouvoir.
C’est une vie assez agréable.
Mais le problème c’est qu’on se retrouvait à vivre chez sa mère.
Ce qui ne faisait pas vraiment une carrière.
C’est quelque chose qui...
c’est juste qu’il y a des limites au pouvoir et à l’importance dont on dispose
quand on doit vivre chez sa mère.
Puis vint le crack.
Pour paraphraser Malcom Gladwell, le crack a été, pour les cités,
une sorte de sauce tomate « avec de vrais morceaux à l'intérieur ».
(Rires)
Parce que le crack a été une incroyable innovation.
Je n’ai pas le temps d’en parler aujourd’hui.
Mais si on y réfléchit, je dirais que dans les 25 dernières années,
de toutes les inventions ou innovations qu’a connues ce pays,
la plus importante, quant à l’impact sur le bien-être des gens
qui vivent dans les cités, ça a été le crack.
Et ce pour le pire ; pas pour le meilleur mais pour le pire.
ça a eu un énorme impact sur leur vie.
Bon, que peut-on dire du crack ?
Il procure très efficacement un effet psychotrope.
Parce qu’on peut fumer le crack, mais pas la cocaïne,
et que fumer est un procédé qui délivre bien plus efficacement l’effet psychotrope
que priser.
Et il s’est avéré qu’il y avait un public qui ne savait pas encore qu’il voulait du crack,
et quand celui-ci est arrivé, il l’a vite su.
Et ça a été la drogue parfaite. On peut le vendre...
on achète la cocaïne qui le compose à $1, on le revend à $5.
Elle rend très vite dépendant ; son effet est très bref.
Ainsi, l’effet est génial pendant 15 minutes.
Puis quand on est redescendu, tout ce qu’on veut c’est retrouver cet effet.
Le crack a crée un fabuleux marché.
Et pour ceux qui dirigeaient les gangs,
cela a semblé être un très bon moyen de s’enrichir.
En tout cas pour les dirigeants.
C’est à ce moment que nous intervenons.
Enfin, pas vraiment : je ne suis qu’un figurant dans cette histoire.
Mon co-auteur, Sudhir Venkatesh, en est le protagoniste.
C’était alors un étudiant diplômé en mathématiques motivé
qui a décidé de passer un doctorat de sociologie.
Il est allé à l’université de Chicago.
Trois mois avant d’arriver à Chicago, il avait
suivi les Grateful Dead.
Et, selon ses propres termes, il avait l’air d’un « déjanté ».
C’est un Sud-Asiatique, un Sud-Asiatique à la peau très foncée.
Un homme grand à la chevelure, selon ses propres termes, « allant jusqu’au cul ».
Il mettait à mal les classifications : était-il blanc ou noir ? Était-ce un homme ou une femme ?
Il était vraiment étrange à voir.
Donc il se pointe à l’université de Chicago.
Et le célèbre sociologue William Julius Wilson
était en train d’écrire un livre qui impliquait d’enquêter sur des gens dans tout Chicago.
Il n’a jeté qu’un coup d’œil à Sudhir, qui allait enquêter pour lui,
et a décidé qu’il savait exactement où l’envoyer :
dans les logements sociaux les plus durs et les plus connus.
Pas seulement à Chicago mais dans tous les États-Unis.
Ainsi, Sudhir, enfant de banlieue aisée qui n’avait jamais vraiment côtoyé les cités,
en bon élève a pris son cahier et s’est rendu dans ces logements sociaux.
Il entre dans le premier bâtiment.
Le premier bâtiment ? Bon, personne...
Mais il entend des voix, plus haut, dans la cage d’escalier, alors il monte.
Et, dans un coin, il tombe sur
un groupe de jeunes afro-américains jouant aux dés.
Nous sommes dans les années 90, au pic de l’épidémie de crack.
C’est un boulot dangereux, être dans un gang : on n’y apprécie pas d’être surpris.
On n’y apprécie pas d’être surpris par quelqu’un qui se pointe au détour d’un couloir.
Le mantra était : on tire d'abord, on pose les questions après.
Là, Sudhir a eu de la chance.
Son allure décalée
et son cahier lui ont sans doute sauvé la vie : ils se sont dit
qu’aucun membre d’un gang rival ne se pointerait avec un cahier pour leur tirer dessus.
(Rires)
Bon, ils ne l’ont pas vraiment accueilli chaleureusement, mais ils ont dit :
OK, écoutons les questions de ton enquête.
Sans mentir, la première question de l’enquête qu’il était censé poser était :
« Comment vivez-vous le fait d’être pauvre et noir en Amérique ? »
« Comment vivez-vous le fait d’être pauvre et noir en Amérique ? » (Rires)
Ça fait se poser des questions sur le monde universitaire...
(Rires)
Les réponses possibles étaient : « Très bien », « Bien », « Mal » et « Très mal ».
Sudhir s’est rendu compte que la vraie réponse à cette question était la suivante :
« Va te faire foutre. » (Rires)
Finalement, ce n’est pas l’enquête qui a vraiment motivé Sudhir.
Il a été retenu en otage toute la nuit dans la cage d’escalier.
Il y a eu pas mal de coups de feu,
pas mal de discussions philosophiques avec les membres du gang.
Au matin, le chef du gang est arrivé.
Il a considéré Sudhir,
est arrivé à la conclusion qu’il n’était pas une menace et ils l’ont laissé partir.
Sudhir rentre chez lui. Il prend une douche, fait la sieste.
Vous et moi, sans doute, face à cette situation, nous nous serions dit
bon, je vais plutôt écrire mon mémoire sur les Grateful Dead.
Je les ai suivis pendant ces trois derniers mois.
(Rires)
Sudhir, lui, y est retourné directement, s’est rendu dans les logements sociaux.
Est monté à l’étage, le second étage, et a dit : « Salut les gars.
J’ai passé un très bon moment à traîner avec vous, cette nuit.
Je me demande si je pourrais recommencer ce soir. »
Et voilà comment a commencé ce qui est devenu une belle relation
qui a fait de Sudhir un résident non permanent du logement social pendant dix ans,
à traîner dans des planques à crack, aller en prison avec les membres du gang,
avoir les vitres de sa voiture explosées à coup d’armes à feu,
avoir des descentes de police dans son appartement avec confiscation de ses disques durs...
À peu près tout ce qu’on peut imaginer.
Au final, l’histoire s’est bien terminée pour Sudhir,
qui est devenu un des sociologues les plus respectés du pays.
Et surtout pour moi, qui, assis à mon bureau avec ma feuille Excel ouverte,
attendais que Sudhir vienne et me livre les dernières données
obtenues du gang.
Sans doute une des relations entre co-auteurs des plus inégales...
(Rires)
... mais je suis heureux d’en avoir été le bénéficiaire.
Bon, qu’avons-nous trouvé ? Qu’avons-nous trouvé dans ce gang ? Laissez-moi vous dire
que nous avons eu un accès complet à tout le monde dans le gang.
Nous avons pu le voir intégralement, de la base au sommet.
Ils ont eu confiance en Sudhir, une confiance que jusqu’ici aucun chercheur,
qu’aucun étranger au gang, n’avait jamais réussi à obtenir de ces gangs.
À tel point qu’ils nous ont laissé consulter ce qui était le plus intéressant pour moi :
leur comptabilité, les rapports financiers qu’ils tenaient.
Et ils nous les ont fournis.
Et pas seulement pour les étudier : nous pouvions aussi leur poser des questions sur leur contenu.
Si je devais résumer rapidement, dans le peu de temps qu’il me reste,
les conclusions qu’on peut tirer de ce gang, c’est que
s’il fallait comparer le gang à une autre organisation,
on pourrait dire qu’un gang, c’est comme McDonald’s.
Malgré des différences évidentes, comme les restaurants McDonald’s
D’abord, d’une manière qui n’est peut-être pas la plus intéressante,
mais qui permet de poser des bonnes bases, dans son organisation.
Dans la hiérarchie du gang, ce à quoi il ressemble.
Voici donc à quoi ressemble l’organigramme du gang.
Je ne sais pas si vous vous y connaissez en organigrammes,
mais si vous aviez à construire un organigramme résumé et simplifié d’un McDonald’s,
c’est exactement à cela qu’il ressemblerait.
Maintenant, ce qui est fascinant, c’est que le sommet du gang
se nomme réellement « Conseil d’administration ».
(Rires)
Pour Sudhir, ce n’est pas que ces gars aient une appréhension fine
de ce qui se passe dans l’entrepreneuriat américain.
Mais ils ont vu des films comme Wall Street et, finalement, ils en ont appris
un peu sur l’organisation du monde extérieur.
Ensuite, au-dessous du Conseil d’administration, on trouve essentiellement des vice-présidents de section,
des gens qui contrôlent, par exemple, le sud de Chicago, ou l’ouest de Chicago.
D’ailleurs, Sudhir avait bien sympathisé avec le malchanceux qui s’était retrouvé
à essayer de gérer la franchise de l’Iowa.
(Rires)
Ce qui s’est avéré, pour ce jeune gang noir, ne pas être le plus brillant
des investissements qu’ils aient faits.
(Rires)
Ce qui fait que les gangs ressemblent vraiment aux McDonald’s, ce sont les franchisés.
Les gars qui dirigent les gangs locaux, vous voyez,
quartier par quartier,
ils sont d’une certaine manière comme les gars qui dirigent les McDonald’s.
Ce sont des entrepreneurs.
Ils obtiennent le contrôle exclusif de la vente de drogue.
Ils obtiennent le droit d’utiliser le nom du gang qui les chapeaute, pour le merchandising et le marketing.
Et ce sont eux qui font du bénéfice ou se retrouvent en déficit,
selon leur habileté à gérer le commerce.
Maintenant, le groupe auquel je veux que vous réfléchissiez, cependant, c’est la base,
l'infanterie.
Le plus souvent, ce sont des jeunes
qui passent leur journée debout au coin des rues à vendre de la drogue.
Tâche extrêmement dangereuse.
Il est important de noter que la masse, la majorité des gens
dans cette organisation, sont à la base.
Oui, comme dans un McDonald’s.
D’une certaine manière, ces fantassins, c’est comme les personnes
qui prennent votre commande dans un McDonald’s.
Et même, ce n’est pas un hasard s’ils se ressemblent tant.
En fait, dans ces quartiers, ce sont les mêmes.
Les gamins qui travaillent dans un gang sont en fait
en même temps, souvent à temps partiel,
aussi employés chez McDonald’s.
Ce qui, je pense, confirme les conclusions dont j’ai parlé,
à savoir que c’est un travail pourri que d’être dans un gang.
Parce que, évidemment, si appartenir à un gang était un boulot si merveilleux, si lucratif,
pourquoi donc ces gars iraient-ils travailler au noir chez McDonald’s ?
Bon, à quoi ressemblent les salaires ? Vous pourriez être surpris.
Mais en s’appuyant sur des faits,
en discutant avec eux, en consultant leurs archives,
voilà à quoi cela ressemble quant aux salaires.
Le salaire horaire pour les fantassins était de 3,5 $ par heure.
C’est en dessous du salaire minimum, n’est-ce pas ? Et on le sait de sources sûres.
C’est facile à voir à leur manière de consommer.
Ce n’est pas de la fiction : c’est un fait.
Il y avait très peu d’argent dans le gang, surtout à la base.
Maintenant, en cas de promotion -- chef local, par exemple,
l’équivalent d’un franchisé chez McDonald’s --
on se fait 100 000 $ par an.
Ce qui, d’une certaine manière, est le meilleur poste qu’on puisse espérer obtenir
quand on a grandi dans ces quartiers en tant que jeune noir.
Quand on arrive au sommet,
c’est entre 200 000 et 400 000 $ annuels qu’on peut espérer se faire.
Et là, on parle d’un succès intégral.
Ce qui est triste dans tout cela, c’est qu’assurément, parmi les nombreuses ramifications
dans le milieu du crack, les individus les plus talentueux dans ces communautés
se démenaient pour cela.
Ils n’essayaient pas de s’en sortir de manière légale
parce qu’il n’y avait pas de moyen de s’en sortir légalement.
C’était le meilleur moyen.
Et en fait, c’était sans doute le bon choix pour tenter de s’en sortir, cette voie.
Pensez-y.
La comparaison avec McDonald’s s’arrête ici.
L’argent est quasiment le même.
Mais pourquoi est-ce un mauvais boulot ?
Les raisons à cela c’est que, constamment,
on vous tire dessus.
Donc, si on se fait tirer dessus, quel est le taux de mortalité ?
Pour notre gang, il faut admettre qu’il n’était pas réellement
représentatif de la moyenne.
C’était une époque d’intense violence, de nombreuses guerres de gangs,
et ce gang, en fait, avait pas mal de succès. Mais cela avait un prix.
Et donc le taux de mortalité, sans parler du taux d’arrestation,
d’emprisonnement, de blessure, le taux de mortalité de notre échantillon
était de 7% par personne et par an.
Au bout de quatre ans dans un gang, les probabilité de décès sont de 25%.
C’est un maximum.
Pour comparer, évoquons d’autres voies
qu’on pense être extrêmement risquées.
Prenons par exemple un meurtrier
accusé d’un meurtre et envoyé dans le couloir de la mort.
Il s’avère que le taux de mortalité dans le couloir de la mort,
quelles qu’en soient les causes, dont l’exécution, est de 2% par an.
(Rires)
Il est donc plus sûr d’être dans dans le couloir de la mort que de vendre des drogues dans la rue.
Ça fait réfléchir, ça fait réfléchir ceux qui, parmi vous, pensent
que la peine de mort a un énorme effet dissuasif contre le crime.
Maintenant, pour que vous voyiez à quel point la vie dans les cités était mauvaise au temps du crack,
et je ne m’appuie pas que sur les points négatifs,
il y aurait là d’autres histoires à raconter,
si l’on regarde le taux de mortalité
de n’importe quel jeune noir qui a grandi dans les cités des États-Unis,
ce taux de mortalité à l’époque du crack était de 1%.
Ce qui est très élevé.
On parle là de mort violente ; c’est dur à croire, d’une certaine manière.
À titre indicatif, comparons avec les soldats en Irak,
par exemple, ceux qui font la guerre maintenant : 0,5%.
Littéralement, les jeunes noirs qui grandissaient
dans ce pays vivaient dans des champs de bataille, presque exactement
comme ces soldats qui, là-bas en Irak, font la guerre.
Alors pourquoi donc, on peut se demander, quiconque accepterait-il de se tenir
à un coin de rue à vendre de la drogue à $3,5 de l’heure,
avec 25% de probabilité de mourir dans les quatre ans à venir ?
Pourquoi faire cela ? Je pense qu’il y a deux ou trois réponses.
La première, d’après moi, c’est qu’ils se font avoir par l’histoire.
Avant, entrer dans un gang était un rite de passage.
Les jeunes contrôlaient les gangs et, en vieillissant,
quittaient le gang.
Ce qui s’est passé, c’est que
ceux qui se sont trouvés au bon endroit au bon moment,
ceux qui dirigeaient les gangs au milieu des années 80,
sont devenus très très riches.
Il était donc logique de penser que la génération à venir
allait remplacer la précédente, comme ça avait toujours été le cas,
que cette génération à venir allait prendre la main et les richesses.
Cela ressemble étonnamment, je pense, au développement rapide d’Internet, non ?
Les premiers à Silicon Valley sont devenus très très riches.
Alors tous mes amis se sont dit « Peut-être devrais-je faire cela moi aussi. »
Ils ont accepté de travailler à bas prix, pour des stock-options qui ne sont jamais venues.
D’une certaine manière, c’est exactement ce qui est arrivé à ceux que
nous étudiions : ils acceptaient de commencer par la base.
Comme, par exemple, un avocat dans un cabinet,
un avocat débutant qui accepte de commencer en bas de l’échelle,
à travailler 80 heures par semaine pour pas grand chose,
en se disant qu’ils vont un jour devenir associés.
Mais ce qu’il s’est passé c’est que les règles avaient changé : ils n’ont jamais pu devenir associés.
En fait, ce sont les mêmes qui dirigeaient les principaux gangs à la fin des années 80
qui les dirigent encore à Chicago, de nos jours.
Ils n’ont jamais transmis leurs richesses.
Alors tout le monde s’est retrouvé coincé avec un boulot à $3,5 de l’heure et ça a été un désastre.
Autre chose : les gangs étaient très très bons en marketing et manipulation.
Par exemple, une chose que les gangs faisaient, c’était,
vous voyez, les chefs se déplaçaient avec toute une cour,
conduisaient des voitures de luxe et portaient des bijoux de luxe.
Ce dont Sudhir s’est rendu compte, au bout d’un moment, à traîner avec eux,
c’est qu’en fait ils ne possédaient pas ces voitures.
Ils les louaient, parce qu’ils ne pouvaient pas se permettre de posséder des voitures de luxe.
Et ils ne portaient pas réellement des bijoux en or : c’était du plaqué-or.
Tout cela revient au vrai-vrai contre le faux-vrai.
En fait, ils avaient tout un tas de trucs pour tromper les jeunes et
leur faire croire qu’entrer dans ce gang, c’était une bonne affaire.
Ainsi, ils donnaient à un gamin de 14 ans
ils lui donnaient une liasse de billets qu’il pouvait garder.
Ce gamin de 14 ans se disait : « Eh ben dis donc ! »
Il allait raconter à ses amis :
« Regarde tout ce fric que je me suis fait dans le gang. »
Ce n’était pas son argent, jusqu’à ce qu’il le dépense. Dans les faits,
il avait une dette envers le gang et était temporairement un employé débiteur de celui-ci.
Bon, il me reste quelques minutes.
Permettez-moi une dernière chose.
Je ne pensais pas que j’aurais eu le temps de le faire, de vous parler
de ce que nous avons appris, plus généralement, sur l’économie en étudiant les gangs.
Les économistes ont tendance à utiliser un jargon.
Souvent, nos théories sont affreusement contredites par les données.
Mais en fait, ce qui est plutôt intéressant c’est que dans cette configuration,
il s’est avéré que certaines des théories qui ne fonctionnaient pas si bien
dans la vraie économie fonctionnaient très bien dans l’économie de la drogue.
D’une certaine manière parce qu’on est dans un capitalisme débridé.
Voici un principe économique :
c’est une des idées fondamentales dans l’économie du travail, l’« écart compensatoire ».
Il repose principalement sur l’idée qu’il faut augmenter le salaire d’un travailleur
pour qu’il soit indifférent à l’idée d’accomplir deux tâches
dont l’une est plus désagréable que l’autre ;
c’est ce qu’on appelle l’« écart compensatoire ».
C’est ce qui explique pourquoi on considère que les éboueurs doivent être mieux payés que ceux qui travaillent dans les parcs, OK ?
L’exprimer comme l’un des membres du gang rendra l’idée plus claire.
Donc il s’avère -- peut-être que je mets la charrue avant les bœufs --
il s’avère que, dans le gang, quand c’est la guerre,
on paie les fantassins deux fois plus que d’habitude.
C’est exactement le concept.
Parce qu’il ne veulent pas prendre de risques.
Des propos tenus par un membre du gang l’explicitent joliment.
Il dit : « Est-ce que tu resterais là quand il y toute cette merde » (c’est-à-dire les coups de feu)
« Avec toute cette merde qui t’arrive dessus ? Non, hein ?
Alors si on me demande de mettre ma vie en jeu, il faut abouler la monnaie, mec. »
Pour l’essentiel, je pense que ce membre de gang décrit de manière plus pertinente
la situation que le font les économistes.
(Rires)
Voilà un autre exemple.
Les économistes parlent de théorie des jeux :
pour tout jeu entre deux personnes, il y a un « équilibre de Nash ».
En voici la traduction pour les membres de gangs.
Ils expliquent sur quoi repose la décision de ne pas utiliser les armes à feu ;
c’est une chose qui s’avère être une importante tactique économique dans les gangs :
si on arrive et qu’on tire en l’air sur le territoire d’un autre gang,
tout le monde a peur d’aller y acheter sa drogue.
Les gens viendront dans votre quartier.
Mais voilà ce qu’il dit pour expliquer pourquoi cela ne se fait pas.
Il dit : « Si on se met à jouer avec nos flingues dans le coin », sur le territoire d’un autre gang,
« personne, je veux dire, tu vois, personne va se pointer chez eux.
Mais faut faire gaffe,
parce qu’ils peuvent venir jouer avec leurs flingues ici aussi, et là on est tous baisés ».
(Rires)
Eh bien c’est exactement le même concept.
Mais là encore, les économistes se trompent parfois.
Il y a une chose qu’on a observée dans les données, c’est qu’elles semblaient, quant à...
Le chef du gang est toujours payé, n’est-ce pas ?
Peu importent les problèmes économiques, il est toujours payé.
Alors nous avons des théories sur la circulation de l’argent
et l’absence d’accès au marché du capital et autres.
Mais quand on a demandé au membre du gang
« Bon, comment se fait-il que vous soyez toujours payés mais pas vos employés ?»
Sa réponse a été : « T’as tous ces nègres au-dessous de toi qui veulent leur job, tu vois »
Si tu commences à perdre du fric, ils vont te prendre pour une pauvre merde. »
Et j’y ai pensé et je me suis dit :
« Les PDG s’octroient souvent des bonus de plusieurs millions de dollars,
même quand leur compagnie perd beaucoup d’argent.
Et il n’est jamais venu à l’esprit d’aucun économiste que cette idée
d’être pris pour une “pauvre merde” » pouvait être importante.
Mais peut-être... peut-être que cette « pauvre merde »...
que cette « pauvre merde » est une hypothèse pertinente qui demande une analyse plus poussée.
Merci beaucoup.